Okay, perhaps we can start a few seconds
before the formal, official time of
starting the session,
because I wanted just to mention one
business item,
which is the person that was supposed to
originally chair this session, and
of course present, is
Ayelet Erez. Unfortunately, she could not join us.
We're going to be able to hear her presentation,
except that she's going to be the last one in the session.
And I was asked to chair in
her place.
And one of the things that I was asked to do, which was her
role, was to introduce the session.
I found out about it just yesterday
evening, so I had to
write something, and I will
use my note to do the introduction.
That's not so difficult,
because the topic that we will discuss today,
which is the host interaction, needs really not much by
way of an introduction. We know that over the past
decades, it has been clear that
cancers do not evolve in isolation, but are shaped
continuously by the immune system, by the stroma, by the
vasculature, metabolism, and microbiome.
And these things are going to be interweaved into the
discussions today.
This dynamic and
bidirectional interaction
can restrain tumor growth, can drive immune
escape, and can fuel progression and
therapeutic resistance.
So the presentation that you will hear today will illustrate
how, by dissecting these complex
relationships, we're not only refining our
understanding of fundamental tumor biology,
but also uncovering new host-directed
strategy to prevent, detect, and
treat cancer more effectively.
So with that,
I will be the first presenter
of the session. Enough I can have my
slide on.
Okay.
So with immune therapy becoming a key
pillar of cancer cure, the
identification of factors that
regulate a tumor immune environment
is becoming imperative.
What
I would like to do in the next 20 minutes is to share with
you our efforts to understand how
host-dependent immune determinants that operate at the
systemic levels can shape the
pancreatic intra-tumoral immune circuitry.
We chose to address this question
using exercise, physical activity as a modality
for several reasons.
Okay.
I need to get my slides working.
Okay. The first is that
exercise really epitomized the engagement of
systemic
host determinants because the effects of
exercise on changes in
hemostatic mechanisms is mediated
by multiple organs.
The second is that the
beneficial effects of exercise on immune health are
mediated by increased circulation of immune cells
and reduced inflammation. Inflammation is a very
well-known risk factor for pancreatic cancer.
Third is that there are now significant number of studies in various
cancers who are showing that exercise
can reduce the risk of cancer recurrence and
cancer-specific mortality in
several cancers. And most relevant to
pancreatic cancer is the fact that
observational studies have shown that
exercise improve the clinical care of
the disease.
So with that then, we decided to
look at-- This is a background, we decided to look at the
effects of exercise on pancreatic cancer.
The experimental system that we used to explore this exercise
immune axis in PDA involves the
orthotopic implantation of cells
from the specified genetic background,
which is mutant p53, into the
pancreas.
We then take the animals
that are implanted with the cells and
subject them to a mild,
controlled aerobic exercise. For those of you who study
exercise physiology, you will know that the mild
aspect of it is very important, and critically important
is a good view of the Empire State Building that the mice
are enjoying. At the end of the exercise
regimenWe harvest the tumor, we subject them to
gross analysis, to immune phenotyping, and
additional readout that we are using, but I'm not going to describe today,
is metabolomics and proteomics analysis.
The overall goal is to identify immune
effectors that could be harnessed for
the design of interception strategies.
So how does it look?
This is a typical experiment when we
implant the animals, let the cells grow
for 12 days, and after day 12, they are
subjected to the exercise training regimen, with, of
course, the appropriate control.
The exercise regimen lasts for 21 days.
What we saw is a
decrease in tumor growth, which is quantified here.
But what we also observed is that this
anti-tumor effect of exercise is being abrogated if we do the
same experiment in Rag1 knockout animal,
suggesting that the protective effect of
exercise is depending on mature T
cells. Or mature
lymphocytes, I should say. And that, of course,
raised the question of what are the effects of
exercise on the immune environment of
these tumors? And to do that, we
phenotyped the cells using
RNA-seq analysis. And
there's no need to do a lot of computational work to
see that there are really two major immune populations that
are changing. MDSC cells are
reducing, and effector T cells are largely
expanding. I'm not going to spend much time talking about the
MDSC cell reduction, other than
saying that this reduction is associated most
likely with
reprogramming of the bone marrow and
the myelopoiesis in the particular
axis of
hematopoietic stem cells differentiation.
On the
effector T cells, first of all, what we found
out is that, in fact, what we see on the
RNA-seq is represented also in the
tumor bed itself. There is a significant increase in
the CD8 positive cells. But
also,
importantly, these cells really show
effector properties by demonstrating activation
or by increase in activation marker and
cytotoxic markers.
And then last but not least,
the effects of exercise are abrogated when the
CD8 cells are
eliminated using antibody depletion,
suggesting that
this particular axis, exercise CD8 cells, are
critical for the anti-tumor effects of
exercise.
So what do we know about these
CD8 cells? Well, we know that they're coming from
the circulation.
You're going to have to take my word for it.
I don't have time to show all the evidence, but I'll come back to it because it's a
very important mechanism in the tumor protective
effect of exercise.
We also know that they are enriched for IL-15
receptor,
and that they also demonstrate an
enrichment for IL-15 receptor
downstream effector pathway.
If we neutralize IL-15 using anti-IL-15
antibodies, we see again that there is
an abrogation of the anti-tumor effect,
indicating that this axis, the IL-15/IL-15R,
is in fact
critical for this anti-tumor effect
of the exercise.
Now, in order for this pathway to be activated,
IL-15 has to come from somewhere.
So we checked which cells in the tumor
environment is producing IL-15,
and we found out that there are both immune cell populations,
the tumor cells themselves, and the stromal cells that are
producing IL-15. There is another very important
component during exercise that is producing
IL-15. IL-15 is a major myokine
that is produced by the muscle
during exercise.
So this is how we think about what exercise
is doing in the setting of immune
activation in the pancreatic
orthotopic transplants.
And
I mentioned the
immune cells or the CD8 cells that I described coming from the
circulation. So exercise is well known to
activate
the SNS axis, which involves centrally
stimulation of the adrenal medulla to produce
catecholamines. Catecholamines are well known to
induce aa process called
exercise-induced leukocytosis.
And what it means is that the stimulation of the
adrenergic receptors on the surface of the immune cells
cause them to slough off the marginating pools, both
in the bone marrow and in the
vasculature. So in the setting of the experimental
system that we have, what we believe is happening is that during
exercise, there is a release of catecholamine, and you can see,
in fact, that we can see an increase in the levels of
epinephrine in the blood of the exercised animals.
This results in immune cell mobilization.
The population that is relevant is CD8 cells,
some of which are just effector cells, and some
of it are expressing the IL-15
receptors. The cells are then being recruited to the
tumor bed, in which, of course, the activated cells
will exert their cytotoxic effect.
And in fact, we do see in the cells from the exercise
cell apoptosis.
But then importantly, this effect is sustained
by
the cells that are producing the IL-15.
IL-15 stimulation of immune cells is
associated not only by activation but also by
expansion. It stimulates the proliferation of the cells.
So that is
essentially maintaining the level of
activated T cells in the tumor bed as long as the
exercise is continuing.
Okay.
We wanted, of course, to convince ourselves that this
axis is relevant to human disease.
This was done in collaboration with Florencia McAllister and Kerry
Schadler from MD Anderson, where they have run a very,
very small trial on patients that
are undergoing neoadjuvant therapy and
subjected a cohort of these
patients to exercise. And what they
observed is that
exercise is associated with an increase
in just the abundance of the CD8 cells, but
also increase in the
presence of activated
CD8 cells. And again,
take this with a big grain of salt.
The
exercise
patient are showing, in the exercise
patient, high levels of CD8 and high
levels of granzyme B, which is an indicator
of activation, is associated with improved
survival. So minimally, what it suggests is
that
the CD8-mediated anti-tumor effect that is triggered by
exercise might be relevant to human
disease.
The second is just a
TCGA analysis that we have performed.
This is from human data demonstrating that there is a
good correlation between IL-15 receptor expression
and
activation markers.
So then the next stage was really to ask the question:
What is the translational relevance of
this axis, the IL-15 immune activation, the
IL-15 receptor immune activation, axis?
And we thought that perhaps a most straightforward and
direct way to
ask this question is going to be by using a
pharmacological activation of the IL-15 receptor
using the IL-15 receptor superagonist, which
is that time, was provided to us by Novartis.
So this is the experiment that we conducted.
No exercise, just administration of
IL-15, a good reduction in tumor
growth, and target engagement as
indicated by the expansion of IL-15
receptor expressing cells.
Now, the activated
cells are expressing all the properties
of
effector
cells.
And importantly, what we found is that under these
conditions, there is also extension of
survival of the animals. This is just administration of the
IL-15 superagonist. Now, not too
surprising under these conditions, since the cells are activated,
there is an elevated expression of PD-1, and that
raises the possibility for us that perhaps
IL-15 can improve the efficacy of
anti-PD-1 treatment. This was
looked at in this particular experiment, and
really the takeaway from this experiment was that the
combination of anti-PD-1 and
IL-15 superagonist was really much
improved in terms of extending survival
relative to each one of these agents alone.
So, this then was the basisFor
a Phase 1b2 trial that we are initiating
any day, all the approvals are in place for
evaluation of
efficacy of IL-15 with anti-PD-1
in neoadjuvant chemoimmunotherapy for
pancreatic cancer.
Okay. So most patients are
presenting
with metastatic disease, and therefore, it was critical for
us to ask the question in the last few minutes of,
what are the effects of exercise on
metastatic disease? For this, we used an experimental
system that some of you may want to take note of,
because in most cases, patients are presenting
with both primary tumor and metastatic lesions.
But most of the experimental systems that are being used are being
used by introducing the metastatic cells to the organ of
interest without the presence of the primary tumor.
And you will figure out, we'll see in a second why it is important.
So this is a dual orthotopic system where we
start off with the introduction of cells into the pancreas.
After one week, we go in and introducing the cells to the
liver. We let the animals settle down.
They look actually quite okay. And then we
subject them to the exercise regimen.
We see that there is a reduction in the growth in the
pancreas, which is good, means that the system is still responding
as expected. But alongside, also a significant
reduction in the liver
metastasis.
So of course, we wanted to know what are the immune changes that
are happening in the pancreas and liver under these
circumstances. And what we found out, and this is just
analysis of what I'm sharing with you, just the major subtypes of the
cells. What we found out was actually very interesting in
that,
or maybe expected, but still interesting, which is the
immune milieu of the liver shows changes
that are not necessarily present in the pancreas.
In both cases, there is an increase in CD8 cells,
but for example, in the liver, there is an increase in
B cells, which is actually quite uncommon,
at least for us as we saw it in other scenario, and a
mild increase in NK cells.
B cells are complicated or complex cell
types when it comes to anti-tumor immunity, but we
still wanted to ask the question, are they relevant?
And so this is a B cell depletion experiment.
We used anti-CD19 and anti-B220
antibodies. And what we find out is that
the depletion
not only doesn't
affect
or doesn't impair the
anti-tumor effect or metastatic
effect of the exercise, but is associated with
enhanced growth of the cells. So there is some
interesting effect of the presence of B cells in
this tumor microenvironment.
Now, we were, of course, interested in knowing whether there is an expression of
IL-15 receptors, because we thought maybe we're going to get a
two-fer.
Activation of the
axis is going to work both for metastasis and for
primary. But you can see that there is a very, very small
population of the B cells
that are expressing the IL-15 receptor.
So,
how the B cells are exerting their anti-tumor effect.
This is work in progress, but we have a hint.
We found out that most of the B cells are
essentially plasma cells that are producing antibodies.
And,
as some of you may know, plasma cells, via the
production of these antibodies, can exert a killing
effect on the tumor cells. So
perhaps there is really a collaboration here between the B
cells,
affecting the
metastatic disease, by killing
the
tumor cells themselves.
Okay, so the very last data slide, and I think
that it is
quite provocative. I don't know how to explain it, but
maybe some of you will have some ideas in the Q&A session.
So since we have the primary tumor and the
metastasis in the same animal, we wanted to ask the question,
to what extent the effect of exercise on each one of these
sites is dependent on the presence of the
other site? In this particular experiment, we asked the
question was, if we remove the primary tumor, is the
effect of exercise on the metastasis is altered?
And what we found out is, so what we do is instead of
injecting cells into the pancreas, we're
doing sham injection. And under these conditions, what we
found out is that there is a complete loss of
the effect of exercise on
the-on the metastasis
in the liver and on the immune cell
populations that are changing. This raises the question
or raises the idea of a
cross-organ communication that is
going on and is potentially critical
for
the effect that we see on the metastasis.
We, for the time being, ruled out the possibility that
it's
pancreas-derived exosomes, but we really think that it's the
metabolic changes that exercise induces in the
pancreas that might be responsible for these
cross-talk.
Okay. So to summarize,
what I was hoping to share with you today is the
idea that the systemic effects of exercise
can shape a host immune environment that is less
favorable for tumor development and may increase the
effectiveness of immune therapies.
Tons of questions remain to answer.
Here is just some of them. Is exercise-dependent immune
axis relevant to other mutant RAS tumor?
Is it specific for the pancreas? Of course, how
does it relate to what we're seeing in other tumors?
Are there durable changes that are induced by exercise that affect
long-term cancer risk and outcomes, as opposed to the
acute effect? Some ideas that we can
share later on. And then,
how do exercise induce changes in systemic physiology?
There is loss of weight. There is a general
change in metabolism, how they influence anti-tumor
immunity and response to therapy.
So a lot to do, a lot to discuss. I'm looking forward
to the question session. But if you
take away nothing from this
lecture,
I just want to share with you this thing, exercise
is good for your health. If Anderson
Cooper is suggesting it, you have to follow him.
And I am
going to close by thanking the individuals from the
lab that participated in this project,
and
collaborators and funding agencies.
So I will stop here.
And I can stay for a few minutes to
entertain questions before I invite
the second speaker for the session.
So thank you for the
so strong education. I think the access is very important.
But another question is for the patient, if the patient
just experienced with several rounds of the, no matter it's
chemotherapy or the different kind of the therapy, the
patient is pretty weak. So what is the strength for the
exercise for them is suitable to accept
the exercise?
Yeah, so that's why we move to the pharmacological,
to mimic what exercise is doing, to try to mimic what exercise is doing
by pharmacological activation. So by learning
what is important during exercise to create the effect,
we identify a pharmacological way that will allow us to
avoid having to put patients with many
comorbidities in an exercise regimen.
But for those of you who are studying pancreatic cancer,
patients that have this disease are extremely
motivated. The exercise itself, and that's why I
emphasize it's a very mild exercise.
What you need, it's
a fast walk,
basically 30 minutes a day, three times a week.
And we have tried it already on patients.
Thank you.
Thank you for sharing impressive data.
I'm just curious about, is there any particular reason to
choose the pancreatic cancer as a model of this study?
And do you expect, will there be any difference among tumor types?
And
the last one is, the last study for the primary
tumor,
if you remove primary tumor,
exercise didn't make any difference.
For the explanation for that data,
could tumor type can be the answer?
So-
Yeah, so-
I mean, the liver cancer. For liver cancer, exercise
doesn't make any difference or something like that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So I think that, well, I can tell you the reason why
we have pursued pancreas cancer, because
this is the disease that we've been studying now for decades.
So selfishly, this is what we're working on.
But in introducing these results,
I wanted potentially to motivate people
to start addressing it in other tumors.
And my guess, or more than a guess, is I believe that it's
going to be specific for every tumor, but the
common theme that I believe is going to be applicable to all
of them is the, it's the immune system that
is going to be very much involved in the
protective effect.
Daphna, you went very fast, and I think I
understood that what you said is that if you
sham the primary but still do the
secondary
in exercise, you didn't get the benefit, correct?
Mm-hmm.
Have you tried to not sham, to actually put the primary,
mimic
getting rid of it? I know that's terribly difficult.
Or to use a metastatic
primary that you can
treat only the pancreas or with a suicide.
I don't know, because it is
so profoundly different when you actually have a primary, and I'm thinking
about the patients that are lucky to go through
surgery, would exercise not be a benefit to
them?
I know that this is sort of a disappointing
potential from this experiment.
The issue is that surgery has a
whole other surgery, a whole other slew of effects
that we're working on now, but it's going to be very difficult to
comparing apples to apples in this situation.
I still believe that there is something that exercise does
to the healthy pancreas that is
very relevant to what we see in the liver.
And those of you who
are up on the physiology
of liver and pancreas will
appreciate that there is a crosstalk going between these two organs
all the time. It's very surprising, and I think we
just need to-- But I just wanted to put it out here for people to
understand that it's not just the organ that we're,
because it's systemic, there are multiple
organs that are contributing to this effect. Yeah.
Shami.
I have a question here.
Very interesting talk. Thank you very much. I have two questions.
The first one is, what are the toxicities of your
pharmacological activator, the IL-15?
No toxicity that we see in the animals, but IL-15
superagonist was approved by FDA.
The one that we use is Novartis, but the immunity bio
superagonist was approved, and that means, of course,
it was improved in bladder cancer.
Of course, when we go to other trial, we're going to have to
phase
1B, so we're going to look at all these things.
It was never done in pancreas cancer patients.
And the second question is, did you look by any chance at the
insulin level and glucose level in the blood?
I'm just thinking that you are looking at metabolic pathway, and especially that
could be driven by exercise and the fact that you have lesions in the
massive
major tissues such as pancreas that can secrete insulin and
therefore can also have an impact on the liver as an
insulin-responsive tissue. I was wondering if you have
modulations of those
hormones and blood glucose.
We just started to look at this,
and as I pointed out, I think it's critical to
ask these questions in the context of metabolism.
Okay.
Yeah. Very good question.
Thank you.
Okay. Couple of quick questions, and we're going to move to the-
Beautiful data. I talk with patients all the time about how effective
exercise is as an anti-cancer therapy, and oftentimes patients and their
families feel flummoxed that I tell them that they can have a piece of cake as
long as they remain active. Have you investigated
how diet interacts with this? Because I've
seen many patients who go keto or long fasting, and then they don't even have
enough energy to come to clinic. So I have a hard time that they would
meet these goals set by exercise.
Yeah.
Probably
diet will affect the outcomes.
I think I shied away a little bit from doing it because
I believe that
food intake by mice and what it does to
mice is just very different
relative. The mouse model is anyhow
different, but when it comes to models of obesity and things of
this nature, sometimes it's very difficult to do the
comparison. I really want to pitch here
something which I think is worth
trying. Exercise oncology, it's an area that has
really not been
looked at carefully. It's logistically difficult
because if you need to have supervised exercise, you need
to actually have a facility, a rehab facility, where the
patients are going on a treadmill, and you actually
measure their exercise. But it's an
opportunity that we owe to ourselves to try,
particularly in diseases where we don't have too much
more to offer. So I believe that this is
something that we need to look at a little bit more
closely on the translational part.
Thank you.
Very interesting new results. I have one question.
So, have you checked the level of CD81 in the B
cells that are infiltrating in your liver mets?
No.
No. Not yet. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. Last question.
Thank you so much. It's really nice data.
So did you also check the differences with the gut
microbiota with the control and exercise mices or?
You asked what the-
The microbiome composition of-
Yes. We did change. There are actually something
there for sure. Just discuss
it with the next speaker.
But not yet that we can say
what it is. So
something that we need to explore. Okay.
So,
thank you very much for your attention.
We're going to move now to the next speaker,
which is
Karuna Ganesh.
She's from Memorial Sloan Kettering, and the title of
her talk is "The Role of pks+ E.
coli in Intestinal Stem Cell
Plasticity and Early Onset of Colorectal Cancer."
Karuna.
All right.
Can I put this down?
Thanks. All right, thank you everyone for being here bright and early
on this Saturday. So these are my
disclosures. So I'm a GI medical oncologist,
and it's been very evident in my clinic, and now the stats sort of
bear that out, that there's been a massive increase in
young people presenting to oncology clinics with a
diagnosis of colorectal cancer. This was historically a disease of people between
the ages of 50 and 70,
and actually, now we're seeing people under the age of 50.
I have patients as young as 16 in my clinic who are
presenting with this devastating disease.
They're often under-diagnosed, getting diagnosed late because these symptoms
of rectal bleeding, weight loss, et cetera, are usually ascribed to other
things, gastritis, whatever, and patients often present late
with advanced disease, which is often incurable.
This trend has been going up actually, if you actually look at the stats,
across the board in Western countries
since the end of the Second World War, slowly over time,
and now really presenting as a clinical crisis.
And the problem is we don't really know what is driving this.
And this has been now the focus of an increasing number of epidemiological studies
as well as others. What we know so far is that this is a disease
that tends to predominate in the rectum and the sigmoid, so the
last part of the intestine, the part that's most exposed to
the air and to oxygen and whatever that brings in terms of the
microbiome, et cetera.
And this has been accompanied also by a decrease in average onset
colorectal cancer in patients over
the age of 50 because we're getting better at getting colonoscopies and
preventing these cancers from occurring.
And of course, we're not screening 16-year-olds for colorectal cancer.
What is driving this? So of course, the first question we ask when we think about
cancer is what are the genomics? And we and many other groups around the
world have looked now at great detail at the genomics,
at the mutations, and the copy number alterations in
early-onset colorectal cancers, as well as those in average-onset colorectal
cancers. And by and large, there's really not much difference.
Of course, there are more genetic syndromes like Lynch syndromes enriched in the
early-onset population. But if you correct for that, the
mutations that we see in people with young onset colorectal cancer are
really the same that we see in average onset colorectal cancer, the
same pathways, APC, KRAS, p53 in the same
proportions. So if it's not the genetics, then what is it?
So this points really to not necessarily something that's
tumor initiating that may be different, but perhaps something that's tumor
promoting, and these are likely to be factors from the environment.
What these factors are have been a matter of speculation, and again, large studies,
diet, obesity, these things indeed do contribute.
But by and large, there are no major statistical differences in
the diet or BMI or other factors like
that in the average onset versus the young onset populations.
And this has led to considerations around the microbiome.
Is there something different in the microbiome of the young onset patients,
which indeed may be driven by other environmental factors like plastic
use, for example?
And among these microbiome factors is this one
bacterium, which has been most strongly associated.
This is a bacterium called pks+ E. coli.
This is an E. coli strain, which produces
this
genotoxic island, which has this genomic island, which is called
polyketide synthase. And what polyketide synthase does is
to catalyze the production of a molecule called
colibactin. This is a genotoxin. This has a cyclopropane
warhead, which allows it to intercalate within
DNA to directly form alkylating lesions,
which are corrected through error-prone repair mechanisms.
And this in turn,
because of this error-prone repair correction, this leaves a
mutation scar in the genome of the
cells that have encountered colibactin.
And this mutation scar is really
shown as a mutation signature that can be detected using
whole genome sequencing. And in this way, they've
identified that there are these mutations that occur
preferentially at AT-rich regions of the genome in a
specific hexanucleotide mutation context, which you see here
as this COSMIC mutation signature, SBS88, most
notably.Some of the things that are emerging, so
pks+ E. coli seems to be associated with
colorectal cancer. In patients who have colorectal cancer, we can find
in their stool microbiome an increase in pks+ E.
coli, but this is not unique to colorectal cancer.
And indeed, whenever we see gut dysbiosis as a
consequence of many different factors, which can include, for example, colitis,
pks+ E. coli is also enriched in these dysbiotic
settings. Also following
extensive antibiotic use, for example, that kills off the
good bacteria in the gut, these populations of bacteria can expand.
And of course, the evolutionary reason to have the pks island is not to
attack our cells, but to gain a selective advantage within the
ecological niche in which the bacteria are competing for resources with
many other bacteria in the same space.
In order to actually infect and attack
epithelial cells in the gut, these bacteria, as you can see here in green,
actually need to physically adhere directly to the apical
surface of the gut epithelium. And this is actually quite an important point,
because usually the bacteria in our gut are unable to directly access the
apical membrane of the epithelium simply because of the mucus layer.
There's a two-layered mucus barrier that
separates the bugs from the epithelium of the gut, and under normal
circumstances, the epithelium is not accessible.
And what happens is that this colibactin toxin is extremely
oxygen labile and has a very short half-life, and is just degraded
before any of that penetrates through that mucus barrier.
So we need to really get rid of the mucus, which happens in cancer, in
colitis, and other conditions where the gut is not working
correctly, which then allows this bacterium to directly stick to the lining
of the gut and then eventually induces mutational damage.
So the problem, as I said, is that we can only detect these mutation
signatures of colibactin exposure in large whole genome
sequencing data. Unfortunately, most of our patients with colorectal
cancer or other cancers in 2026 are not routinely getting whole
genome sequencing of their tumors.
And what we do in most clinical practice, including at ours at Sloan
Kettering, is to do targeted exon sequencing with panels of
genes, with hybridization to panels of genes,
which gives us a much sparser data set.
So it's actually hard to statistically detect these mutation signatures.
And what we wanted to do was to ask, can we develop a method
that allows us to detect these colibactin mutation signatures at scale
across clinical mutation sequencing data sets?
And if so, can we then ask questions about genotype and phenotype
correlation? What can we learn about the tumors that occur in patients
who have this colibactin mutation signature?
And so we went ahead and did just that.
And working with our team, our assay at MSK is called
MSK Impact. It targets about 500 cancer-associated exons.
And we developed an assay to be able to identify and detect with
high specificity, of course, relatively low sensitivity,
given the sparseness of the data, these colibactin mutation signatures in
our clinical cohorts of over 80,000 tumors that have been
sequenced with MSK impact and have rich clinical annotation.
And when we did this, we find that the mutation signature was most
enriched in colorectal cancer, consistent with, of course, what we know about
these colibactin mutation signatures.
And we also find these in other aerated parts of the
aerodigestive tract. And this includes other GI cancers, including esophageal
cancer, but also bladder cancer and some head and neck squamous
cell cancers, which are also colonized by these bacteria.
So this made sense. We were confident in our approach, and we were able to validate
it across what has been learned from whole genome sequencing.
And now we were able to go back to the clinical correlation to ask, what's unique,
what's special about the colibactin signature containing tumors?
And when we did this, the strongest signal that we found was for age.
And indeed, we found across the board that the tumors that harbored the colibactin
mutation signatures tended to be from patients who were younger in
age. These also were more likely to occur in the rectum or the
rectosigmoid area, the left side of the colon.
Again, consistent with what we know about early onset colorectal cancer.
And as we were putting this work together, a paper was published actually last
year, concordant with ACR, which also showed using
900 whole genomes from patients all over the world, that again, there was an
enrichment in the young onset patients for these colibactin
mutation signatures. So we're very confident that this is happening.
So of course, the next question is, what does this mean?
Why is this signature enriched in young onset patients?
And so the first thing we did was to look at the genome, and it has been shown
that there's a specific mutation in APC.
Of course, APC loss is a near universal feature.
Over 80% of colon cancers are initiated by an APC loss of
function mutation that drives hyperactive Wnt signaling.
But APC can be lost in many different ways.
And there is one specific mutation which occurs in a splice
site near the N-terminus of the APC gene, which occurs
in fact, in that AT rich colibactin mutation signature
context. And when we looked at this, indeed, we found an enrichment for this
specific APC mutation across our patients who had the colibactin
mutation signature. And what was really striking is that when we look at
stratifying these patients by age of onset of their disease, the younger
the patient is, the more likely their APC mutation and their
tumor was to be in that colibactin mutation signature context.
Suggesting that in the younger patients, the colibactin mutation was
likely the initiating driver event for initiating these
tumors. However, when we looked at the rest of the genome, we really didn't
see any differences, no major differences in tumor mutation burden
overall or copy number alteration in the colibactin signature
positive or negative patients. And so this led us to
hypothesize, in addition to inducing this mutation, could
the colibactin toxin be doing something else
to promote the progression of these cancers?
So does colibactin mutagenesisimpact the phenotypic
state of these tumors. And this has sort of reminded
us of work that we've been doing in my lab, where we've really learned that
as tumors progress from the normal colon to the primary tumor to the
metastasis, these cancer cells, despite having the same
mutations, acquire a sequence of cell state transitions
that enable them to have increased plasticity, first into a highly
conserved intestinal stem cell-like state, which is the cell state that the
tumor cell population needs to be in in order for a mutation to turn into a
tumor, and then eventually into increasingly more plastic states to allow
adaptation during the metastatic process.
And the mutations are the same, but these additional phenotypic changes
confer increased ability to become aggressive cancer.
And this is also happening in the context where we now know
work from the Sanger in the UK has shown that across all adult human
epithelial organs, including the gut, we know that by the time we get to
adulthood, all of our epithelia harbor mutated cells.
And in fact, we can find all of the oncogenic driver mutations, including those in
APC, across completely morphologically normal
appearing epithelia. So the mutation itself is necessary,
but certainly not sufficient to drive the formation of a cancer.
So this is what we were asking, could colibactin do more?
To do this, of course, we needed a good model system, and we like to do things in
human tissues. But the challenge here is that the bacteria has to
stick to the lumen, into the apical aspect of the
tumor or the epithelium in order to actually induce the
mutagenesis. And the problem here is that when we use organoid culture,
which is how we normally study these interactions,
the apical aspect is on the inside of this tightly
barrier-forming organoid. And so how do we get them in?
We could microinject, very painful and not even really possible in mutated
organoids, which actually do not often have big lumens.
And so we took advantage of what we know about organoid biology, that the
polarity of organoids is maintained by basal
contacts of integrins expressed on the basal
membrane of the epithelium with the laminins and
other matrix proteins that are present in the matrigel.
But we know that if we disrupt this barrier, as you can
see here, the organoid can actually flip inside out on
itself, basically inverting its polarity.
And now the apical side, which is normally on the inside, is exposed on the
outside. And so we took advantage of this to really create a
model system where we could simply remove the organoids from
matrigel and put them transiently in suspension culture to induce this
flipping, the acrobatics of these organoids, to expose the apical
lumen to the outside. We could then come along with a suspension of
pks+ or delta-pks control bacteria that
do not harbor the pks island that makes colibactin, and
then we can flip them back. And indeed, we are able to do this.
And when we add the bacteria, we see that these green GFP
positive E. coli are now incorporated inside the
lumen of the
organoid, and they retain their viability in
this context. And then basically what we did was to flip back and
forth with this model system, to do long-term culture, to enable the
mutations to be acquired and for the mutated cell population to be selected.
And then we asked, indeed, could we see with whole genome sequencing,
evidence of this mutation signature suggesting that this model actually works, that
the bacteria were actually able to secrete the toxin, and the toxin could do
its job in the system. And indeed, that's what we found, that we found when
we look at controls that have either not undergone any of this flipping, week zero,
or controls that have undergone flipping, but in the absence of bacteria or
in the presence of delta-pks E. coli, so they experience all of the stress
of being exposed to bacteria, lipopolysaccharide, et cetera, but
not colibactin. And then finally, the pks+ E.
coli that harbor the colibactin island.
And when we do this, we see with whole genome sequencing that we see the
colibactin signatures exclusively in the
organoids that have been treated with the pks+ E. coli in this way.
So this validates our model. And the next question we then asked
was what happens with acute exposure to the bacteria?
So now if we go back and expose the
organoids to the bacteria just for 24 hours, what is the
immediate response of the epithelial cell population
to exposure to pks+ E. coli, controlling for this with
delta-pks E. coli? So we are not looking at bacteria-specific effects, but
simply colibactin-specific effects.
And when we do this, we see upregulation with RNA-seq and proteomics
of DNA repair
associated programs. This is not surprising and again, serves as a nice control,
because indeed, these organoids that are being exposed to
the colibactin genotoxin are going to experience this
mutagenic stress.
And then we asked, what else could be going on
here in terms of the phenotypic state?
So what I already told you is that in order to make a tumor, the
mutated cell must eventually enter into an intestinal
stem cell-like state. And what this state is, is a cell state that
normally exists in homeostatic intestines at the bottom
of the intestinal crypts marked by LGR5 and other Wnt target
genes. These are the cells that are capable of self-renewing and give
rise to all of the daughter cells of the intestinal crypt.
They divide and differentiate, and actually every five days or so, we have an
entirely new gut lining. And so, the cells
that divide and differentiate are eventually lost into the lumen of the gut.
But the self-renewing population is this LGR5 population at the base
of the intestinal crypt. So in order for a tumor to
occur, we need to have, of course, this APC tumor-initiating
mutation. That can happen in the LGR5 cell itself,
that can then serve as a cell of origin.
But alternatively, we now know that the gut is a very plastic
organ, and if you get that mutation in a differentiated cell type,
if that cell type is now able to dedifferentiate and switch
back into an LGR5 cell, that is also capable
of inducing a tumor. So this was the question we were asking, could
colibactin mutagenesis, in addition to inducing an APC
mutation in some cases, could that also be doing something to influence the
cell state to drive these cells into a more pro-tumorigenic state?
And when we did this, we looked with single-cell RNA-seq at our organoids that had
been treated with pks+ or delta-pks E. coli.
And indeed, we found that even though all these organoids
expressed stress signatures, which is not surprising given that they're being
exposed to bacteria and LPS,
there was an enrichment, surprisingly, of the intestinal stem cell program
in the pks+ E. coli treated organoids.
This was really surprising because most other stresses we
give these organoids actually push them away from the stem cell state into a
more injury repair regenerative state.
And in fact, we see the opposite here.We also see upregulation of
markers that are well characterized of this Wnt-driven intestinal stem cell stage,
including Lgr5 and Ascl2. And we can see this both
in tumor organoids that we treat with pks+ E.
coli, as well as from our normal colon organoids from a
number of different patient donors, suggesting that this is really a shared
biology.
Functionally, what does this mean?
So we can assess functional stem cell function
by seeding cells from organoids as single cells, and these
cells must then dedifferentiate and switch into an Lgr5 stem cell state
in order to form and regenerate new organoids.
And again, we found that when we treated the organoids with pks+
E. coli, we saw increased functional stem cell
ability, the increased ability to form new organoids relative to when
we treated the organoids with the Δpks E.
coli, suggesting again, a functional enrichment of this
Lgr5 expressing stem cell program.
This also resulted in long-term increased proliferation in the
pks+ E. coli treated organoids. And then we asked,
how is this happening? How is this working mechanistically?
And to ask this question, we teamed up with the lab of Ileana Cristea at
Princeton, and we were able to do a technique called TPC
mass spectrometry. So this is thermal protein co-aggregation mass spectrometry,
which involves basically,
when exposed to pks+ or Δpks E. coli, what we
now do is to treat the cell as a bag of protein-protein
complexes, and we can melt these protein complexes by treating
the cell suspension at different temperatures and then running mass spec,
with the idea being that more stable protein-protein complexes will
melt at higher temperatures than less stable protein-protein interaction
complexes. And in this way, we can look at what are the protein complexes
that are preferentially stabilized only in the presence of pks+
E. coli and not in the presence of Δpks.
And here again, when we do this approach, we see again enrichment of the DNA
repair complexes. But intriguingly and really strikingly, we also
see at this resolution chromatin remodeling complexes.
And when we look at what chromatin remodeling complexes are being formed, these are
all repressive complexes, complexes that are involved in turning
off gene expression. So what could this mean?
So to understand that better, we then performed ATAC-seq on our organoids.
This looks at chromatin accessibility, in pks+ versus
Δpks organoids. And again, we see across the
entire genome, we see a decrease in chromatin
accessibility in the pks+ E. coli treated
organoids. When we looked now at the motifs of
transcription factors that are capable of binding to these lost peaks,
this is now when we really had an aha moment, because what was really
striking without even looking at the specifics of the transcription factors, are
the sequences of their motifs. We saw that the motifs that were repressed
were largely AT-rich, whereas the motifs that were opened
and enhanced in accessibility in this context were largely
GC-rich. And indeed, this AT-rich motif reminded us, of
course, of the colibactin mutation signature.
This is where colibactin binds and can mutate, but
perhaps also does more than just mutate and does more in terms of
repression. And indeed, the top gene, whose transcription
factor binding motif was repressed in pks+ E.
coli, was Cdx2. And this was really impressive and
intriguing for us because Cdx2 is a transcription factor that we
need to make the entire intestinal differentiation program.
So repression at this locus suggests that the cell is turning
off the differentiation program, and by default, then
dedifferentiating into a stem cell state.
And indeed, when we looked at the Cdx2 specific targets, we see
a decrease in accessibility there.
We've also now done Cdx2 cut and run to show that the direct binding of
Cdx2 is impaired when the cells are treated with pks+
E. coli.
And then we also were able to do some AlphaFold 3 structural modeling.
And we tested the hypothesis in silico, that
Cdx2 binds here to the minor groove of
DNA at these AT-rich regions. And then when we
modeled colibactin, that fitted beautifully into that exact
same binding site for Cdx2, suggesting that there could be
direct competition between colibactin binding and the
displacement of Cdx2 from its promoters in the
minor grooves of AT-rich regions in the genome.
The same thing was also true for Hoxb13.
Hoxb13 is a transcription factor that is not expressed in the adult
gut, but it is expressed during gut development and is required for gut
development. And perhaps this plays a role in early
exposures in the neonatal period.
When we went back to patient samples which had whole genome sequencing,
we were also able to find enrichment of these same transcription
factor binding motifs at the same sites where we found colibactin
mutation scars across the genome, sort of validating in clinical data
our hypothesis that we derived using the patient
organoids.So finally, how does this then link, this
idea that colibactin can block
CDX2 accessibility to its transcription factor binding sites in the genome
and induce dedifferentiation? Why does this then preferentially cause
early onset colorectal cancer, and why would this mechanism not be at
play also in average onset colorectal cancer?
So to understand this, we had to think about what is the difference in the stem
cell biology
with aging, what happens in the young, and what's different as we age.
And so we turn to a single set data set that we had in my
lab from young and old colons. These are adjacent normal
colons from patients who have colorectal cancer somewhere else in their gut.
And we see that there's a decrease with aging of the intestinal stem
cell population. And indeed, these aged intestinal
stem cells show signatures of replication stress
and S-phase stalling. And so when we grew
organoids from young and old guts, normal colons, we find that the
young guts proliferate faster. And when we treat the
young organoids with pks+ E. coli versus older
organoids with pks+ E. coli, we find that both the young and
the old gut experience injury, but the old gut is not able to
regenerate effectively after injury.
And these cells simply die and are lost into the lumen of the gut and are
replaced by other healthy cells. Whereas in the young gut, because
these epithelial cells retain increased regenerative capacity,
they're able to tolerate the colibactin mutational stress, but then
repair them with these error-prone repair mechanisms, induce the mutation
signature, and then couple basically the
oncogenic mutation together
with the cell state switch into the LGR5 positive state,
which allows for effective tumorigenesis.
So this is really our model, where we think that in addition to the
mutagenesis, which we think happens in the subset of cases, we think it is
much easier for the colibactin to induce a
phenotypic switch into a stressed but then
regenerative LGR5 positive stem cell state, which then
couples the mutagenesis with tumorigenesis
entry into a phenotypic state that is permissive for
cancer generation. And
this idea that there is this mutation signature that
uniquely provides a selective advantage to these
cells, then provide us with a way to start to look
in healthy guts, potentially to start
screening for patients who might benefit from more aggressive
monitoring or potentially therapeutic intervention.
So I'll stop there, and thank, of course, the phenomenal
team in my lab that has done all this work, our patients who donate their tissue,
our funding, and happy to take some questions.
I would like just--
Since the last presentation is recorded,
what I want to suggest that we do is you can use the
QR code to send your question for Karuna.
Let's go through the presentation and then, because we're not going to have a
Q&A session for the last presentation.
So,
stay around. Can you load up the third presentation?
Hello, everyone. Thank you for joining this session.
I truly wish I could be there with you.
I'll just say that we hoped and are always
hoping that eventually science will bring peace to our land
and to the Middle East.
So today, I'll be talking to you about the tumor host
crosstalk.
And when I say crosstalk, I mean how the host with the age,
exercise, diet can affect tumor growth.
But on the other hand, how does
the tumor affect the host by inducing inflammation, metabolic
rewiring, and eventually cancer cachexia.
And our idea was that if we can understand and dissect this
crosstalk, maybe we can modulate it to restrict
cancer progression and improve therapy.
And I will start by giving you an example how
drugs that the host is taking for other indications, not cancer,
can affect tumorigenesis. And as example, I will use
sildenafil, also called Viagra. So what
Viagra does, it inhibits phosphodiesterase 5A,
causing an increase in cyclic GMP.
To evaluate
the ability of sildenafil to improve cancer patient
survival,
we
analyzed the digital database available to us at the Weizmann,
which includes digital health data of 5 million
people that have been followed by the Israeli healthcare system for
20 years. And I'm showing you here a Kaplan-Meier curve
demonstrating that those patients who were taking sildenafil and
diagnosed with lung cancer had a significantly improved
survival compared to those patients with lung cancer who were
taking antidepressants such as SSRI,
confirming that the effect of sildenafil is
not mood related.
When we looked closer, we found that this is true for almost
any cancer for which we had enough male patients.
So I'm showing you here colon cancer, prostate cancer, pancreatic cancer.
In all of them, we saw that sildenafil or
Viagra improved cancer patient survival
significantly.
To show that this effect is specific for the function of
Viagra, which is to inhibit phosphodiesterase
5ASince the patent expired, we looked at
other PDE5A inhibitors, and all of them
improved cancer patients' survival.
I'm showing you here prostate cancer.
In contrast, when we looked at another PDE, this time
PDE10A inhibitor, another commonly used drug called
fapervirine, we saw no effect on cancer patients'
survival. So we wanted to understand how does sildenafil
improve cancer patients' outcome.
In order to do that, we first did several in vitro
experiments in which we treated cells.
I'm showing you here the results for breast cancer, but we did it in multiple
cancers. And you can see that when we treated cancer cells with
sildenafil, we significantly inhibited colony formation,
we inhibited migration, and we also restricted lung
metastasis.
To show
that it's specific to the inhibition of PDE5A,
this time we used SH or PDE5A, and we showed
that cancers harboring the SH PDE5A,
had significantly lower number of metastasis.
So how does PDE5A inhibition affect metastasis?
For this, we did transcriptomic, proteomic, and what we found is that
the pathway that is most significantly
upregulated is cholesterol metabolism.
So cholesterol is synthesized by several enzymes that are
regulated by the nuclear translocation of
SREBP-2, leading to increased transcription and
eventually to increase in cholesterol level.
So we did a time course, and we looked at the levels of SREBP-2
as well as the other enzymes, and we can see that half an hour
within treatment of sildenafil, we see elevation in the
nuclear fraction of SREBP-2, and
eventually we see elevation after about
six hours in all the downstream enzymes that are
responsible for cholesterol synthesis.
So where does cholesterol accumulate?
We saw with BodyP that cholesterol
accumulates in lipid droplets, and when we did
specific analysis of different organelles within the cell,
we saw that sildenafil
induces the accumulation of cholesterol
specifically within the lysosome.
This
accumulation of cholesterol specifically within
lysosome reminded us of a known inborn
error of metabolism called Niemann-Pick C.
This is caused by mutation in NPC1
gene. And as you can see, this is taken from one patient with
NPC1 deficiency. Cholesterol accumulates within lysosomes
similar to what we find following treatment of cancer cells with
sildenafil.
So why does this happen? It's because NPC1 is the
transporter of cholesterol from the lysosome into the
cell, and when NPC1 is mutated, there is
decreased availability
in cholesterol. In order to test our
hypothesis,
we looked for specific interaction between
cyclic GMP, which is the downstream
metabolite that is increased following sildenafil, and looked for
potential interaction with cyclic GMP and NPC1.
And as you can see here by showing you a
simulation,
cyclic GMP competes with cholesterol on the binding to
NPC1, and if we modify cyclic GMP,
this interaction between cyclic GMP and
NPC1 is lost. And indeed, when we
measured cholesterol, we saw that there is significantly
decreased availability of free cholesterol following
treatment of cancer cells with sildenafil.
So how does the accumulation of cholesterol in
lysosome affect cancer patients' survival?
For this, we did lipidomic analysis, and we found significant
changes in lipid composition following treatment of
cancer cells with Viagra. As you can see
here in the cells treated with sildenafil,
there's
depletion of cholesterol from the cellular
membrane, leading to decreased in
membrane fluidity and metastasis.
What was interesting was that if we treated the
cells that received sildenafil with cholesterol, we
rescued the cellular membrane. So what is the
therapeutic relevance?
To confirm that the effect of sildenafil or Viagra on the
cancer cell membrane is indeed
contributing to the effect
on cancerous features, we treated the cancer cell with
Viagra, and as you can see here again, it restricted migration.
But when we added cholesterol to the cells, the effect was
lost, and when we combined the two,
there was no migration. So cholesterol rescued
Viagra's inhibition of cancer cell migration.
And next, we wanted to see whether this has therapeutic implications.
If we deplete cholesterol, would it be
beneficial?
So to see whether
the combination of depleting cholesterol and
sildenafil would be synergistic, we measured apoptosis,
and
we treated cells either with sildenafil, resulting in 4%
apoptosis. However, when we combined sildenafil with
mediumWith lipid depletion, we
increased the apoptosis significantly.
To further examine the therapeutic relevance, we now
treated the cancer cells with Viagra and cholesterol-depleting
agents such as Lovastatin. And again, as you can see, we
significantly decreased cancer cells
confluence.
Finally, to confirm the therapeutic relevance, we went
back to the digital database I told you before.
And as you can see here, cancer patients, lung cancer
patients that were taking sildenafil together with
statins had an even better and much improved,
and more significantly
increased survival compared to either sildenafil alone,
statin alone, and of course, to no treatment.
So to summarize this part, I showed you that patients that are
taking PDE5 inhibitors for definitely
different indications other than cancers, have
increase in cyclic GMP leading to
decreased cholesterol availability because of the binding of cyclic
GMP to NPC1, which is the cholesterol
transporter, leading to cholesterol accumulation within the cell,
decreased cholesterol availability.
There is a secondary attempt to compensate for the decrease in
cholesterol availability by increasing cholesterol
biosynthesis. However, the decreased availability
of cholesterol remains, and there is disruption to plasma
membrane, decreasing metastasis, and
if we combine sildenafil with statins, we
significantly improve cancer patient survival.
For the second part of my talk, I'll focus on how the tumor
affects the host, mainly by looking at cancer
cachexia.
So cancer-associated cachexia is a late-stage metabolic syndrome
affecting almost 80% of cancer patients, and it's
directly responsible for about 20% of cancer
death. We all know these famous pictures of Steve Jobs and
Patrick Swayze when they lost a lot of weight
and became dependent on others for even
basic functions.
Cachexia starts with fat loss and progresses to muscle protein
loss, and currently, there is no effective biomarker
or treatment for cancer cachexia.
In previous work, we showed that cancer-induced systemic
inflammation leads to infiltration of innate immune
cells to the liver, secreting CCL2,
recruiting more and more innate immune cells, which lead to
depletion of H&F4 alpha. As you can see here in mice
with mammary pad tumor, breast cancer tumors 41,
there's complete depletion of H&F4 alpha even
though the cancer does not metastasize to
the liver.
This is important because this depletion of the master
metabolic regulator of liver
metabolism affects glycolysis, amino acid
metabolism, fatty acid oxidation, and
oxidative phosphorylation.
To show that the depletion of H&F4 alpha directly
cause or contribute to cachexia, we used
SHH&F...
Okay, I did ask to
stop for a few minutes this presentation because it will go for
another 10 minutes. I did want to
offer Karuna the opportunity to answer questions
if there are any for her presentation.
There is one that
is...
Can you activate? Yeah. Okay. There is one that came
on the
Q&A line, and the question was whether
you have done any experiments on immunocompromised patients
or models.
Well, would you test whether
being immune compromised affect the profile?
We cannot hear. I see. So I think the question was whether we've done any
experiments on immunocompromised patients or
models. So, of course, the experimental work that we did was
mostly in in vitro models, so there is no immune system there.
We have also done similar things in vivo in mouse
models. And indeed, we see the same pattern.
So I think at least the
effect that we're seeing is really mediated by direct contact on the
epithelium. Of course, the responses to this could be mediated
also through the immune system and worth thinking about in the future. Yeah.
Eddie?
I tried to remember my questions. I wrote them down.
Can you expand a little bit on the splice
mutation that you found to be critical in
young, but
I will say overcame in old?
Yeah.
Thanks, Eddie. So the APC can be lost in many different ways,
and this particular mutation basically just messes up a splice site,
such that you get a misfolded RNA, and then that's
decayed through nonsense-mediated decay.
And so it's just that specific mutation happens to be in this
AT-rich context, which is found in the Colibactin mutation
signature. So there's, of course, some inference happening
here that we think that that mutation happens in a Colibactin mutation
context. Of course, there are other ways you can get the same mutation, but we see
that specific mutation in that AT-rich context is enriched in the
younger onset patients. So that seems to be the driver
mutation for inducing the tumor in younger people.
And the younger you get, the more likely that the APC mutation that they have is
that specific splice site mutation.
So that
splice
isinhibited?
Because you said that the bacteria
will restrain the AT-rich
areas.
So the bacteria, in this case, is mutating through the
colibactin, that AT-rich region, which is a splice acceptor
site.
It is mutating. Okay.
That site, it is mutating.
Got it. Thank you. Sorry.
No.
I had another question, now I forgot.
Yeah. Okay. Two quick questions, quick answers.
Thank you very much for the wonderful presentation, Dr. Ganesh.
I have a question about this
analysis you did with MSK-impact cohort.
The MSK-impact cohort is basically, you explained it is based mostly
on whole exome sequencing and targeting sequencing.
And as you mentioned earlier,
the result of mutation signature analysis depends heavily on the absolute number of
mutations, which means why, whole genome sequencing has always become the
standard in analyzing mutational signatures.
And the colibactin itself is not a very strong mutagen.
Quick question. We need to move.
Okay. So I was wondering if you can
be sure or ensure that the result of mutational signature analysis
using whole exome sequencing or targeting sequencing could be comparable to the
results you do with whole genome sequencing.
So absolutely, it's not going to be as sensitive, so we are missing a lot of
cases that likely have the signature, but it's extremely specific.
So we are very confident that the signatures that we find are definitely the right
ones, but we are certainly missing a lot.
Thank you.
Shami.
I was just thinking that,
just to get your thoughts on if there is anything to be learned from the
germline FAP patients that present at a very
young age and you can have access to a carpet of polyps, right?
If PKS positive E. coli,
if they didn't have a parent who had FAP, if it played a
role in utero, and if anything is known
along those lines.
Yeah. It's a great question. There are two cohorts epidemiologically looking at
this, at the Fred Hutch and at Vanderbilt.
And the de novo FAP is an
incredibly rare subset, so it's very hard to say anything about that.
But what they do know is that they haven't looked yet at the mutation
signatures, although we're encouraging them to do that.
But what they look at is the current colonization of the
epithelium with PKS positive E. coli.
And there doesn't seem to be a good correlation between current colonization
and the presence of the polyps. And I think this
holds with this idea of this being a hit-and-run mutagenesis probably happening in
very early life, then manifesting as tumor later in life.
Thank you.
Okay, so we will
return to Dr.
Ayelet Arad's presentation,
but that's going to take us to the very end of this
session. I want to thank the attendees for
coming and for a very
productive discussions, and enjoy the rest
of the meeting. And if you can put the second part of the
presentation, we would appreciate.
Virus and depleted AGNF Alpha in the livers of healthy
mice, wild type mice. And still, we could show
that even just the depletion of AGNF Alpha from the
livers of these healthy mice was enough to generate cachexia,
so these mice lost weight.
It induced fat changes, and they also had decreased in
body mass.
So what is the therapeutic relevance?
We treated
mice with pancreatic
cancer with AAV carrying the mRNA for
AGNF Alpha, and we showed that these mice maintained
weight and had decreased fat loss and increase in
muscle fiber. And of course, we also
improved their survival. Even though these mice had both cancer
and virus and the survival was increased by only 10 days, it was
still significant.
As another
beneficial side effect, we show that the treatment with
mRNA of AGNF Alpha significantly restricts tumor growth.
So our aim is to detect cancer patients at risk
and treat them with early drug
interventions or diet, but also maybe with
mRNA for AGNF Alpha.
At around the same time, Shiling Shen, who is now an
investigator at MD Anderson, but at the time he was at Duke,
was visiting the Weizmann Institute, and he had a
paper published in "Science" showing that there is a gut-brain
communication through the vagus nerve.
And we were thinking maybe the vagus nerve, which also innervates the
liver, can also communicate between the brain and the liver
when there is cancer.
And maybe the vagus nerve also regulates AGNF
Alpha.
So Shiling inserted an electrode, which was able
to specifically record
the vagus nerve output
in the place where it innervates the liver.
And I'm showing you here a recording from a healthy mouse.
This is a recording from the vagus nerve.
However, in mice with cancer, you can see that this
recording is completely distorted.
To further understand this, we looked at LLC mice.
These mice have subcutaneous
tumorsNot even orthotopic. And
still you can see in these mice, complete depletion of HNF
alpha in the liver, even though, as I said, the
tumor is outside the liver in the flank,
subcutaneous tumor. So we wanted to see whether we can
connect the dots. So we first looked at the
macrophage infiltration and saw that in mice with cancers, the
macrophage specifically innervate
the
vagal nuclei. We then showed that in those
vagal nuclear region where there's
infiltration of the macrophages, there is
also activation of these vagal
nuclei.
Then we were able to show that in these mice who were carrying
the lung cancer tumors, there is increase
in the brain CCL2. If we
add CCL2 to primary neurons, we are able
to activate them. And finally, if we add
acetylcholine, which is the vagus transmitter, we're able to
show a decrease in HNF alpha in naive
hepatocytes.
So what I showed you is that basically the same pathway
is now
involving the brain. The cancer induced systemic inflammation
leads to macrophage infiltration to the brain, CCL2
secretion, this time activating the vagus, leading to
HNF alpha and maybe to cachexia.
So this was our question, whether we can modulate the vagus
nerve to alleviate cachexia.
So to do that, we performed vagotomy, which basically cuts the
vagus nerve that innervates the liver.
And we induced lung cancer in these mice that
either went through sham surgery or vagotomy.
As you can see, the mice with sham surgery developed
cachexia. However, those that received
vagotomy,
even though the tumor grew,
maintained their weight and activity.
You can see it here clearer within the weight graphs
that those mice that received just vagotomy or
no treatment at all,
this is what their weight was. Those that received no treatment
lost a lot of weight due to the cancer, and those that had cancer
with vagotomy had improved ability to preserve
their weight and also to maintain
muscle fiber. As you can see here, however, the
tumor mass was not affected
by the vagotomy. So we wanted to
see whether treating mice with lung cancer with
vagotomy and chemotherapy could synergize.
What I'm showing you here is a Kaplan-Meier curve of the mice,
either with lung cancer and no treatment,
lung cancer and treated with either chemotherapy or
vagotomy, and mice with lung
cancer treated with vagotomy and
chemotherapy, mainly demonstrating
a synergistic beneficial effect on
survival.
So as I showed you, we saw that the brain can affect liver
metabolism, and this was also reflected in the plasma amino acids.
However, surprisingly, we saw that those mice that had
cancer and were treated with vagotomy had also improved
food intake. So we were wondering whether there is also an
effect mediated by the vagus connecting the changes in
the liver with the brain.
To understand this, we looked at lipocalin, which was shown to mediate
appetite in pancreatic cancer cachexia.
And also there was this paper showing that if you down-regulate
HNF alpha, lipocalin 2 is elevated,
enabling all the program that is required to
improve
eating.
So indeed, we looked at lipocalin in our mice, and we saw that in those
mice with LLC, there is increase in the liver production of
LCN2. We also saw this increase in the
brains of the mice carrying LLC. And finally,
we found an increase in liver levels of lipocalin
2 in the wild type mice that were treated by
HNF alpha.
So this means that HNF alpha depletion
leads to elevation of lipocalin 2, restricting
food intake and contributing to cancer
cachexia. Basically generating a vicious
cycle where the vagus affects HNF alpha
level, but HNF alpha levels also affect the
brain via the vagus, all contributing to the severe
manifestation of cancer cachexia.
So to summarize
my talk, I hope I convinced you that in addition to the
tumor and studying the tumor microenvironment, there
is a huge advantage in understanding the
patient and how it contributes to cancer
progression, even
with no intentions.
I want to thank all of you for staying with me
throughout this talk, even though I was unable to attend in person.
And of course, thank my students, collaborators, funding,
but most of all, thank you again.